the pandemic forced a lot of small
businesses to adjust their operations
and
some notice a difference when it comes
to the type of orders at the moment
sliding into the holidays we are
changing our approach to things felicia
parker and her family prepare
gift baskets fulfilling orders coming
into any occasion baskets a las vegas
business
operating in the loft space of parker's
mountain's edge home
i've been so thankful and grateful to be
a home-based business during this time
the setup helps cut overhead
costs it also allows parker to continue
managing orders
and adapting to clients needs now
basket orders for the large holiday
baskets for the company events are no
longer being ordered it's the smaller
individual baskets for the individual
employee or customer
a similar scenario for popped a gourmet
popcorn business in henderson
we're pushing more towards the
individual
package the new trend as clients avoid
communal items
thank you the co-owner jean-francois
tells me the holidays remain
crucial it's about 30 percent of our
business throughout the year so we
really look forward for a good holiday
season and hopefully that's gonna you
know put us back on track
on track after a slip in sales because
of casinos temporarily closing and
canceled conventions but francois and
parker expect
business to pick up things are coming
back we're finally starting to get some
corporate orders
both owners say clients seem to prefer
shipping and delivery options to keep
everything contactless
back to you